today's question comes from liberty in
oregon
my husband and i just started fbu and we
want to pay off our debt
fast my husband recently asked if i
would be willing to work some hours to
contribute to our efforts
we have one child and are trying for
another before we became parents we
decided i would stay home because having
a full-time parent with our children was
important to us
what's your opinion on family values
versus paying off the debt
quicker now i'm really curious what you
think about this anthony because this is
a values question
and when it comes to values and anthony
and i give you guys advice on values
you're going to get
our values and those may not be the same
so i'm going to i'm going to jump no no
no no no no go to you first go to
youtube okay okay
okay good evening so one of the things
that i actually like helping people do
and i talk about it in terms of life
balance
but i love helping people figure out
what their values are
and then live their life according to
them for example
if you build a business and you look at
other people how they do their
businesses and you structure
the exact same but it doesn't line up
with your values you're not going to
enjoy your business because your
business should reflect your values
similarly i
when we we give you guys the baby steps
these are proven principles
but the speed at which you do them and
your stage of life and what you're going
through is going to be customized
for you and your values so
when you say that you want to pay off
your debt fast
liberty and you want to stay home
because that's important to you you're
telling me two things you value and two
things that are important to you
what i would say to you is you need to
decide which is more important
which is more important to you paying
off your debt faster
or staying home with your child in the
season and then picking up the pace
maybe when they're in preschool
i would argue and i'm curious what you
think here eo i would argue there is not
a right or wrong answer here because
it's your values but i will tell you
if you do something that goes against
your values you're going to be
anxious and tense and frustrated if it's
really important to you to stay home in
this season
when you have little teeny kids and
you're maybe have another baby on the
way
and then you go work you're going to
feel a lot of angst and at the same time
if you value paying off that debt faster
than being at home you're going to feel
antsy like hey i need to do something i
need to do something i need to
contribute i need to
and so i i would say you have to decide
which is more important to you and it
may be a blend it may be something
that's why i love helping people start
home-based businesses
because during nap time you could be
making some extra money on etsy and then
you're doing both so there are more
options than you think
but i think it comes down to you
deciding your values what do you think
io
when it comes to speed not the baby
steps because the baby steps are proven
but the speed at which you do it
i think the question should be
asked to the couple what is best for
us moving forward and i think the
inside of that conversation my personal
opinion
we identify okay cool do we want to be
out of debt
so we can enjoy we do we want to be out
of debt
quicker so we can enjoy you being at
home not feeling any pressure
not feeling anything with the kids or do
we
mind having a little bit of pressure
while you're at home
so are you saying the same thing i'm
saying are you no okay
of course not of course not go on go on
so what i'm saying
is for me i'm having a conversation and
i'm trying to respectfully convince my
wife
if i'm in that situation um hey i want
you to go back to work
i do not see that i do really
i feel like in this situation your wife
came to you
and i'm not saying there's a right or
wrong because you know i'm pro you doing
what's right for you but if
knowing you yeah and how but now wait i
how do i say this i wouldn't be in this
situation
okay so what i'm saying but if i was in
this situation oh okay
i am asking my wife if she's saying hey
i
i really want to be out of debt i want
to have freedom and i'm thinking
i'm just thinking as a husband and as a
father you know i want my wife to raise
i want my wife to be at home and to
raise our kids
but i also want us to be at home and
we're not we're not we're not we don't
have any pressure we don't have any
stress
and we know finances can be stressful
and so i would
i would have the conversation now my
wife comes and says no i want to stay
home cool beans i'm going to step up
and i'm going to do everything i need to
do uh to eliminate the debt so my wife
can so if she said
if she said it's important to me to stay
home yes you would support that
absolutely
that's cool that's cool yeah that you're
we're we're tracking we're on the same
page
it's interesting too because when we
talk about um
parenting we talk about working we talk
about women working and how and where
and when they work and what that looks
like this is a
deeply personal issue and so i would
just encourage
every woman listening right now every
family listening right now every parent
listening
it is really important for you and your
spouse to have a conversation
where you are on the same page even if
you have to wrestle through it even if
you have to
go see a counselor to work through it to
be on the same page with this because
you can't look to people around you to
tell you what you should do you don't
need to let your parents tell you what
you should do your in-laws tell you what
you should do this is your life it's
your kids it's your
time and i would say as a mom of three
kids age six and under
there is a season when they're little
and that season is very
short and goes fast and so uh
there are women that stay at home and
think i'm crazy for working outside the
home there are women that work outside
the home that
you know they wish they were homework
there's there's so many different ways
to do it
and you need to decide what's right for
you because this is your life
yeah and that's the only thing that
matters is what is right for you
and your family it's a great question
it's a great discussion ao because
and you see it uh across cultures it
varies
across regions the north versus the
south versus
there's so many different ways to look
at it there's a lot that affects it but
have that conversation with your spouse
about what that looks like for you and
how that affects how you approach the
baby steps and also let me say this to
chrissy because i want to make sure that
we're saying is
saying this in a way to where everyone
hears us correctly
chrissy said it there's no right or
wrong answer here
all right so if you are a couple and you
all have kids and both of you all are
working to pay off debt
that is good for you and your family now
if you're one of the couples and
one of you are saying no i want to go
home and do this see chrissy said you
should do this anthony said you should
do that
don't do that because at the end of the
day you have to do what's best for
you and your home and as long as you and
your spouse
have a conversation you all agree stick
to that if you want to stay at home mom
and the husband work or the wife works
doesn't matter that's great for you
um but just make sure you hear us we're
not saying one is better
than the other well and the thing i
would add i said this passively but this
is what i've spent the last six years
doing
that's the reason i love helping women
start businesses from home
it's not that's what you have to do but
if you want to during nap time you have
a hobby you want to turn into some
income you have a skill set education
experience degrees
you want to do consulting or freelance
work or have an online business
that's why i started business boutique
that's why i have the business boutique
book and the
and the events and my coaching because
then it gives you a little bit more
options of you're able to contribute
financially if you want to and use your
gifts
but also you get to stay home and work
those hours around
naps and what matters to you the other
thing i would add to this ao before we
head out here is that that this really
applies whether we're talking about
staying home or not
because we get this question on how fast
do i pay off my debt
how gazelle intense i am and you know i
i know people that they have cut
out their cell phone bill their cable
bill they haven't you know
bought anything not anything for and
that's how they get out of debt really
quick and that's cool but i'm gonna be
honest when i had my debt free journey i
still had a cell phone
yeah you didn't mean and and i didn't i
didn't go on vacations and stuff but you
decide
the intensity that's right for you yeah
and how much how much you want to go
all in for it because it's your life and
your financial journey absolutely and i
saw someone say something yeah if you're
going to get out of debt you need to end
your gym membership i said if i was in
debt right now i'm not ending my gym
membership
that's just me you have to do what's
best for you you can get gazelle intense
you can get gazelle focused
but your journey may look different from
someone else's journey as long as your
mind is set that i am going to become
debt free
by this time that's the main focus of
what we here at ram
solutions are are really suggesting have
a goal a goal a specific
with a deadline and do not be lazy with
it
have a strong specific time of when you
are going to get out of debt
and you and your spouse or you by
yourself and your single focus
and do everything you need to do to hit
that day
that's that date so good it's a marathon
not a sprint
pace yourself for the journey